what are the multiples of a number say
we have a number seven what are its
multiples
how many multiples does it have seven x
one is seven this seven is one of the
multiples of seven seven x two is 14 14
is another multiple of seven the word
says it all a multiple if a number is
multiplied with seven we get sevens
multiple and seven x 3 is 21 and the
list would continue forever
the multiples of seven are 7 14 21 28
and so on this proves that the list of
multiples of a number is infinite for us
the number of factors of a number is
always finite concept of multiples gives
us a very important result let us find
the multiples of 2 2 times 1 is 2 2
times 2 is 4 2 times 3 is 6 and the
multiples of 2 continue what's special
about the multiples of 2 all the
multiples of 2 are called
even numbers yes all the multiples of 2
are even and what about the numbers
which are not multiples of 2 the numbers
which are not multiples of 2 are called
odd numbers so the numbers 1 3 7 9 and
so on are odd numbers this concept of
even and odd numbers is very important
no matter which grade you are in
multiples of 2 even non multiples of 2
odd and now we come to a very
interesting question how our factors and
multiples related let's understand the
relation with the help of a random
number sit 12 to find the factors of 12
we try writing it as all possible
products of two numbers 12 can be
written as 1 multiplied by 12 it can be
written as 2 multiplied by 6 and 3 x 4
these are the only possible combinations
each of these numbers are factors of 12
the factors of 12 are 1 2 3 4 6 and 12
now observe the number 12 in relation
with these numbers 1 multiplied by 12
gives us 12 so 12 is a multiple of 1 2
multiplied by 6 gives us 12 so 12 is
also multiple of 2 3 times 4 gives us 12
and so on what does this imply the
number 12 is a multiple of all its
factors yes this is always true a number
is always a multiple of all its factors
you